hi everyone thank you for joining us
today and a very warm welcome to the
online talk design for good experiences
this event is presented by the society
of experiential graphic design and is
supported by the design singapore
council at the national design center
so today's session design for good
experiences is the third top of the
crafting experiences quarterly series
presented by segd the society for
experiential graphic design we will be
discussing what good experiences
actually entail the mindset of putting
people first and whether anyone can
learn how to design for good the session
will start off with an introduction by
segd followed by a sharing session from
our speakers and wrap up with the q a
segment
and so with that it's my absolute
pleasure to introduce our speakers for
today so first of all we have us steve
lawler co-founder and head of creative
of aya an independent publication and
art platform which uses creativity for
social good it has developed a strong
network of creators for the educational
space and was also a recipient of the
recent 2020 president's design award
steve is a veteran of the design
industry with a career spanning graphic
design advertising art interactive
design and exhibition curation
we also have with us larry pay founder
and creative director of and larry an
independent branding and design studio
recipient of the president's design
award in 2014 and 2016 larry has
produced a body of work that exemplifies
the spirit of collaboration resulting in
innovative experiences and stronger
connections between people and brands
larry believes in leaving his mark not
through his creations but by the good
that they deliver
and last but definitely not the least we
have eric jaya design principle of
thinking room a branding and design
studio based in jakarta
eric is a big fan and practicing
craftsman of emotion driven design and
he believes in creating designs that
resonate with people and creating
environments that centers around
togetherness for his team
moderating our session today are segd
singapore co-chess o'hara roman rick and
jan foley
ola is the creative director at design
build firm devarge where she oversees
projects entertainment attractions
cultural and commercial sectors within
singapore and the region
she believes in meaningful and
purposeful solutions that go beyond
aesthetics or latest trends and is
inspired by designs that break the mode
yan is the founder of widows singapore's
practice and co-founder of retail
architects in paris
embracing multi-disciplinary approaches
yan has a diverse expertise in
sustainable architecture cultural
curation and exhibition design he is
also an associate member of the
singapore institute of architects and a
member of the international council of
museums
it is now my pleasure to hand over the
time to oha and yan who will share more
about experiential design and scgd oha
yan please
good evening everyone and thank you
felicia for this uh introduction we are
honored to be partnering again with uh
design singapore council uh and thank
you for joining us today for the society
of experiential graphic design
singapore's
chapter third in the series of talks
this year titled crafting experiences
stories by experiential designers from
southeast asia
my name is ola romanog and with me is
yang holang as felicia had introduced us
we are the co-chairs of sdgd singapore
chapter and we will be the moderators
for the talk this evening so we have a
fantastic lineup of speakers and uh
today we will be talking about designing
for good experiences so a good
experience is often hard to define in
concrete words and measuring it in its
value and impact can be difficult in the
most direct terms good experiences are
exemplified by how they can shape events
and interactions we share with people
things places services rules and
anything else we encounter in the world
around us there is unlimited potential
of designing for human-centered
experiences from physical to digital and
anywhere in between the mindset of
putting people first can help to create
unforgettable experiences with positive
impact and create the future we want it
to be
so uh thanks uh thanks again everyone
for being here today and thanks olaf for
this introduction the design for good
experiences but what is experiential
design so that's um that's a question
that we always ask so experiential
design in interior for example
integrates multiple disciplines to
create a memorable interaction to
enhance certain attributes in the
overall experience so besides
functionality comfort aesthetic and
integration of the latest technologies
the experiential design also addresses
the psychological aspect of human
interaction with the built environment
so now
if we go to the next slide what is
exponential design and why is it so
important so on the next slide
we can uh see that here the growing
dependence on technological devices is
extensively changing human behavior in
day-to-day life so we need to create
this engagement with the public
spaces
that is beyond the conventional method
uh because it is more and more
challenging and especially in this
pandemic time so whether it is a
marketer an interior designer
installation artist all progressive
professionals basically are
combining their their forces to go into
these immersive experiences in as we as
what we call the edge of experience the
next slide
five major categories of expression
design exhibition design
marketing entertainment placemaking and
environmental graphics so the next slide
so exhibition design is this hybrid of
storytelling and environment that we
find in museums galleries and so on the
next one
we move to marketing like sensory
experiences like time screen new york
guerrilla marketing and product like
product experiences and launches so that
is for marketing the next slide so we go
to entertainment concert and events that
are mainly in this category the one that
we have not been experiencing that much
in singapore from small scale to very
very big scale entertainment
the next one so this place making a
public installation and landmark which
defines the space around us to welcome
everyone you know the last part uh
environmental graphics messages
information or images
those five categories and then we move
to the next one
where it is what is experimentation
graphic design graphic design so
experimental graphic design involves the
orchestration of typography color
imagery form technology and especially
content to create the environment that
communicate so the next one we can see
that this experiences due to
environmental graphic design
can be clear
impactful and human and so that is
whether his way finding or any other
environmental graphics for this
experience so the next one
we have the core component of
experiential graphic design signage and
wayfinding
once again place making and interpreting
so the next one challenging wayfinding
as you can see
so uh those solutions require more than
signage because this pathway visual cues
landmarks and so on that help people to
navigate
through a space that's what we had in
one of the early talks earlier this year
the next one
um interpretive so all of this
information that can tell a story the
meaning of a concept a theme an object
so that is usually what is being used in
the display
in the form of exhibit also interpreted
and the last one place making creates
this distinctive image for a site
and can be expressed in several ways
like
communication and so on towards
architecture interior design and
sculpture all of this
is basically contributing to the
experience
so i guess before we get to know uh
before we start getting to know our
speakers we also want to uh introduce uh
everyone or if you joined us during
previous talks to uh
remind everybody and tell everybody
about segd society for experiential
graphic design so scgt exists to educate
connect and inspire the
multidisciplinary community of people
that
are basically creating these holistic
experiences
so who are we what do we do and what
have we done this year in singapore so
uh if you go to the next slide
we are a community of diverse thinkers
and practitioners we are not just uh
designers on one field but we practice
throughout different disciplines and we
are peer-to-peer supporters of design
thinking and doing we're passionate
about design we are about meaningful
inspiration and engagement and we share
love for design we are svg's we are ncgt
uh so what have we done this year i i
hope you've joined us during our first
two talks where we uh are really
focusing on crafting experiences and we
want to hear the stories by experiential
designers from southeast asia
we focused on environmental graphics and
wayfinding design in our first talk of
the year and we had kelly chang of the
press room yalainu
of foreign policy studio and also
william harold wong of william harold
wong and associates that joined us for
uh to to talk about their experiences in
the field we just have a few glimpses of
what uh what wonderful projects our
speakers have presented so kelly
presented some of the uh the do's and
don'ts in the wayfinding and exhibition
design
um if you go to the next slide
yalang showcased some of her projects
with clever wayfinding and branding
applications and finally on the next
slide william gave us a fascinating
overview of his projects that infuse
vernacular and local flair into signage
and wayfinding design
uh in our second talk we had uh focused
on exhibition and interpretive design
with some of the heavyweights of the
exhibition design community here in
singapore and also
a guest speaker from thailand we had
jackson tong from black laura miyoto
from gsm project and munai chirac porn
from bug studio out of thailand
jackson had introduced us to
a project that was uh very widely known
which is the which is the uh art zoo
laura has transported us into more
traditional experiences in the museum
environment and how she merged digital
and physical experiences to create new
dimensions of interpretation in a
traditional museum space and finally
when i who gave us a fascinating glimpse
into his multi-sensory projects that
combine all senses to create truly
immersive experiences in his projects
and if you go to the next slide we do
have more talks coming up and exciting
lineups if you want to see our first two
talks please do uh
take a look at the segd youtube page
where both of the talks are posted and
you can watch them in their entirety uh
if you have a favorite speaker that you
wanted to catch but didn't uh weren't
quite able to
so uh with with our segd
we are offering a special new regional
membership if you would like to join the
community and take advantage of all of
the benefits the community offers it is
a global
organization and we do have a wide
variety of
connections and resources that are
available for
for the designers that are practicing or
curious about the field so you can see
on the screen you can you can follow the
link below and join uh or check out
about check out more information about
segd
so
so now i think it's time it is time to
uh to discover and to to get to know our
speakers so
we have our this tradition in our scgd
singapore chapter talks where we have
this a really like funny break the eyes
kind of introduction and we wish we
could all be in the same space but we
can also we would like to know a bit
more about steve larry and eric so the
next slide
um
it is what we call the fast and curious
so i think you need to get prepared
because we will start with steve on the
next slide i think it's this so be still
if you want to come on stage if we can
see your video yes hi
so steve
question
yes okay steve i will ask you a question
so sketch pad of computer
computer
computer okay next one timeless or
trendy timeless
next one simple or complex complex
complex black and white of color
curves or lines
controller chaos chaotical
okay
and
[Music]
perfect thank you steve so larry i think
you got a taste of uh what these
questions are so if you could also turn
on your camera so we can get started
with you
yeah hi larry
hello
okay great let's get started
inside or outside inside
okay digital or manual manual okay
fast or cheap bust
midnight oil or olive oil no olive oil
collaboration or isolation
collaboration
great and immersive or subversive
[Music]
okay
thanks very much
eric where are you come on stage turn on
your camera and uh so oh hi eric nice to
meet you again here so question for you
next slide simple or complex
simple
simple hands-on or hands-up
hands-on hands-on linear or organic
organic
temporary or permanent
permanent
timeless or trendy
same with speed uh timeless timeless
okay and pc or mac
mic of course
okay
thank you i think we are doing our first
round of questions so we'll call you
back here very soon because now we are
going into a bit um deeper into uh into
the basically uh the environment of our
speakers with this show and tell
since they are in their offices or in
their home perhaps they can share with
us a little bit more so we will start
again with steve i do steve i think
yeah
and so
um so that steve heyway but steve come
on stage
turn on your camera and come on stage
oh you're here oh great okay so what
does designing for good mean to you
wait is this a question or is this my
slide it's a question
what is designing good mean to me um
i suppose like having a purpose and and
having a sort of it's it's got a longer
life than a three-month ad campaign
okay fair enough
so are you more creative when working
alone in a quiet place or collaborating
in a busy environment
i like intimate settings so either alone
or with one or two people who are i
respect
and you know kind of yeah so i
bend the answer alone maybe if i had to
choose one
what object on your desk do you use the
most
i mean obviously like laptop mouse that
kind of stuff but i've got some like new
stuff on my desk you know i got my new
leader mask from the
[Laughter]
and i got like my funny books you know
my comics like you know these always
come in inspiration
toys things like that
all right thank you steve thanks thanks
for showing a little bit of your desk to
us
so uh next up is larry so larry we will
also uh ask you a few questions and uh
get to know a little bit about you and
about your creative process and the
environment that you work in
so the first question
would be where is the place where you
feel most creative
the toilet
i suppose it could be a one-word answer
yeah okay so next question is there
anything in your office workspace that
is integral to your work process yeah
this um also it's kind of like the
guitar i mean kind of a stress relief
thing
okay i can train my left hand to play
the guitar as well
i find myself pressing this endlessly
throughout the day oh wow
okay okay
and the last question is design
essential for well-being
yeah
yes and no
because you know there's something
that i prefer to be not designed but yet
nature itself is sort of designed
so i guess we are kind of blur the lines
uh so i guess yeah i mean if
yeah i guess
thank you larry so we will move on to
eric now so every come on stage and on
your camera um so we'll have like a few
questions a few similar questions for
you as well uh so on the next slide
what object on your desk do you use the
most
i think used to be my my
my macbook but now it's my iphone maybe
oh wow interesting
okay okay
i play games a lot
but but what do you do when you finish
process
um
i usually move to another project or
another stuff that i that not related to
to design maybe
okay so you have to move to something
else okay yeah yeah yeah
and on the last question so what does
designing for good mean to you
i think design that has a good uh good
purpose
and it could give a good impact to
others as well as to
to ourselves as a as a designer
okay yeah
but thanks a lot thanks a lot for for
all of these answers uh so i think now
we will go into the main core of our
water so thanks eric and we'll call you
back um so
um
so to to our audience you've been
listening to one of these questions like
the fast and colors the show-and-tell so
that gives you a bit of the context of
all of the speakers and so we now go
through the uh the slides and the
presentation of each of our speakers
steve
felicia has already presented who is
steve so the co-founder and the head
creator of ayah
recently the recipient of the president
design award 2020
in singapore
i have the great chance of knowing steve
personally for many many years since i
arrived in singapore and and i would say
he's been very instrumental
in
the graphic design in the design
industry here and even beyond that in
the entertainment industry which is
where i met him
i'm very very happy to have you today
with us and to share basically your
behind the scene in your creative
process so um as we say with much
further ado let's welcome steve on stage
on our vietnam stage
i did say like sorry in advance because
i i only really made this presentation
and i haven't practiced it and it's 24
seconds of 24 slides so i'm just going
to do my best all right and if i waffle
on just just kick me up the bottom
cozy nice and cozy chill
we are all very happy to listen to you
go ahead
okay the fastest way to grow is by
leaving your comfort zone i think i grew
up in hong kong and i never understood
the language and i think
watching films in new languages and
being um the sort of minority really
teaches you uh different viewpoints and
i think this is why this slide is here
next
when you're challenged you exercise your
brain in creative ways what what this is
about is really about trying to um use
creativity to solve problems and this
will become apparent later on but what i
want to make sure is that everybody here
understands that creativity is not just
it's not just assigned to creatives
i was lucky enough to attend fabrica
which is like a kind of creative
communication
um research center and um one of the
famous sort of things that it used to
make was colors magazine and it got me
very interested in the idea of kind of
non-commercial graphic design and visual
communication and what we can do
with the tricks of advertising um
to persuade people to think in in other
ways about human issues
next slide
um you know this first things first
manifesto was initially written in
perhaps 1967 i suggest you screenshot
this slide there's a lot of text but
i'll just tell you briefly it's about um
a movement of graphic designers in the
60s who were worried that
graphic design was becoming a tool for
uh selling things and not using its full
potential and thibault carmen i've put
here is one of my heroes
and if you don't know him please go and
find out more about him who i really
respect and share this philosophy with
of using
design to design to tackle
global issues
so what can we address with uh with our
skill sets i think um
you know everything here
uh graphic design and visual
communication and the design process in
general can address and i think um this
is what i definitely drives me um in
terms of uh visual culture and its uses
and i think again screenshot this if
it's too much to take in um but i think
i'll expand on this a little bit in the
next slide
so i started a magazine called ir with
my colleague tanya wilson and we've been
working in advertising for 20 so years
and i think what we realized quickly was
that it was a waste of
a lot of great artists and illustrators
ability
um and so now we've got this magazine
ayah where we take on different issues
and we go to the next slide our first
issue was about the internet our second
issue was about food
our third issue was about trash our
fourth issue was about
the then we did fake news
you know um
this is 420 people are addicted to the
internet million people but that's only
people that have registered for
council there must be millions more
let's go to the next line
um so with our first issue when we
launched we wanted to make an exhibition
about the internet
and um if you look at the image on the
right or yeah um this is about blocking
unwanted calls and we wanted we wanted
to
show
young people and children in particular
um
how to decode images and the little shot
of adrenaline they get when they
understand an image and it's called a
smile in the mind and i think using
these visual puns to communicate has
been a really effective tool for us and
if we go to the next slide
it's images of our uh launch where we
made an internet house so if you look on
the stairs there's viruses there's
devices on the right there's wi-fi on
the left
we wanted to create this sort of
walk into a magazine if you like i mean
it was fairly low budget so we didn't
have a ton of uh screens or interactive
things but we we really wanted a visual
impact
uh that people would enjoy and if we go
to the next slide we created like a
iphone prison you can see there
everybody enjoying it it was a kind of
photo booth um
we had these little worksheets where
people would go around and find little
easter eggs in the artworks and it
encouraged them to observe and um
kind of
look for things in every single artwork
there was about 40 artworks from around
the world and um and yeah we go to the
next slide
these are some of the worksheets that
they were given so they would they would
then go around and um
and kind of dig a bit deeper into the
show you know sometimes when you go to
an exhibition you're not that engaged
and i think we quickly found that
teachers were bringing their children to
our exhibition because they found it was
a great way of
bringing these topics up for discussion
if we go to the next slide
um
then we got kind of roped into or
invited to start doing workshops and it
wasn't long before we were doing collage
workshops with kids
animation gif workshops and what's
really interesting is when you do
collage you're no longer
hindered by the ability to draw and i
think
young people really were able to express
themselves with with magazines and
newspapers found around the classroom
and around the school and i think this
project in particular
really empowered a lot of the kids uh
who thought they were bad at art uh
realizing that they can put something
down
um we have these creative challenges how
do you trigger imagination okay you
don't need to be a creative director to
do this um here's nine images combine
any three to come up with the title of a
blockbuster movie uh to encourage young
people to do more for the planet you can
screenshot this and you can do it later
but for example a giant roller skating
bear seeks revenge for rising sea levels
okay like i mean there's infinite
possibilities here um and i think
there's no wrong answers which is really
key in in this journey of teaching
creativity
other creative exercises are things like
caption contests again where there's no
correct answer
screenshot this if you want to do it
with your classrooms or your colleagues
or your peers it's a really fun exercise
we often put them on our instagram which
is ir mag
if you want to go and follow that um and
some of the answers you can get better
every time you do a caption contest you
will get better and more creative so
it's measurable
measurable
and of course a lot of these
illustrations just inform really fun
sculptures or really fun
3d ideas and i think that's what i'm
moving to next in these next few slides
is how do we break away from the page
and start to bring to life some of these
visual ideas you know the the car tire
donut i mean it's quite a strong visual
why not let's make it bigger let's make
it like uh tactile something we can play
with we go to the next slide
um
we start to create an exhibition
if you look at the on the wall here
there's a rubbish bin and on the floor
is all of these coffee cups and what we
wanted to do was create a kind of
interactive engagement for kids visiting
this exhibition where they would throw
the coffee
coffee cup tops you know the takeaway
coffee tops
into this rubbish bit
and if you go to the next slide
the idea was this image on the left kind
of inspired this whole exhibition
it was a pop art show using very
interesting visual kind of
juxtapositions and it's by an australian
artist called yaya chloe
um
who you can find on our instagram as
well and it just her work became really
um you wanted to make it into 3d you
wanted to walk into her work
so back to the question can one image
trigger a whole exhibition experience
and if you look at the next slide the
answer is very bluntly yes
we made an exhibition about the ocean
and um
and essentially we had 40 artists from
around the world making gifs and
sculptures and
larger than life artworks that you could
kind of walk into
and you see here there's mini sculptures
there's coral there's a shark cafe
uh we had face filters and jif stickers
so visitors could kind of interact with
the works this was during covert by the
way so it was a no low touch exhibition
so a lot of the interaction was done
through handphones
um but it just goes to show you the
power of one image can really
really trigger like a lot of uh stuff
and then we talk about virtual you know
this is a little jiff sticker exhibition
that we made recently earlier this year
uh where we supplied the public with jif
stickers and they went off to create the
artworks and we made an exhibition of
the public submissions and this
virtually existed online but also on bus
stops uh um
um
around singapore and um yeah so if we go
to the next slide it's it's slightly
different this is not an aya project but
it's a project we did last year um
about akira inspired art so we made an
akira inspired um space
with these
artists from
uh they're from around the region
actually more asia and um we were due to
have this exhibition physical exhibition
but coverage struck
so we we kind of um
we just kind of thought wow lots of
these artists actually one of the
artists the contributing artists made
the virtual gallery so it all kind of
happened quite organically and there's
sculptures and it allowed us for sound
and things like that
so what's next so this if you can see i
know it's quite dark this is an eye that
tracked you around the room at one of
our previous exhibitions called jiff
fest and it's a festival of gifs or gifs
whatever you prefer to say
and it's been running for it's a
two-year event every two years we do um
this celebration of gifs and the next
one coming up will be uh art science
museum in march 2022
and the theme will be anxiety so if
anybody wants to
take part get involved sponsor anything
come just screenshot this now
and follow those hashtags and then you
can get involved okay thanks peace
thank you thank you so much steve um
thanks a lot for for sharing with us
i love you all of your body of work and
it's
very inspiring and very exciting and to
the audience
if you have questions keep your
questions we have a q a session after
that
so feel free to post questions and we
will answer to them at the end so thanks
again steve and now we will go
to larry uh so larry
so please really come and come on stage
so thanks again steve and let's welcome
larry thank you steve so larry who's the
recipient of the president's design
award and if the founder of and larry an
independent branding and design studio
so larry if you could uh please turn on
your video so yeah let's start with your
portion of the of the presentation
so whenever you're ready larry so larry
the floor is yours
uh thanks jan thanks a lot um i'm gonna
start my presentation so every client
brief and outcomes are different so
today i'll try my best to share what
i've learned over the years
um yeah this is what what our studio
believes in a good design disappears and
the great design should touch the heart
it's very easy to say
but um it's very hard to get there so i
always start with good intentions
and then how it feels eventually oh
sorry that's the 24 seconds
i got to speak faster so yeah so yeah
start with good intentions how does it
feel
eventually and then you kind of plan and
work backwards your next slide
um the experience design to me is very
much like my daily vitamin c
pill
it disappears but
what's good remain in you and i love
this
daily ritual so much that um recently i
ran out of me i went to the store
and this lady just over the counter
insists that the chewables are better
than this you retain more vitamin c no i
just want this you see so for the
audience if they love the experience so
much
that you can't tell them otherwise so
that's the um the goal right most of us
next
so um besides your design sense
one of the important things i've found
out it's um over the years is to engage
the five other sensors of course i mean
here's metal touch but
um
to me one of the most important one is
the sixth sense
um
proprioception whatever you call it um
it's intuition
experiences memories uh something we
share as human beings so i i
unfortunately i can't give you a rundown
on how i get there but yeah you know the
sixth sense thing is very important next
slide
um just like what i said um i imagine
and larry to disappear or i i should
disappear after some time so glad to see
after 16 the 16th year um we've changed
our brand mark to nl
so hopefully you don't see me as much
anymore you'll see my team more next
time
um
yeah so for
i mean what we do is more like branding
and we always distill the
essence of a brand so it's almost like
any to me it's very interesting when how
you can extract the entire chicken into
a digestible form like how they
advertise in brands chicken essence
right so focus on the main idea and play
around with these so-called ingredients
that make up the overall experience so
that it doesn't seem so big
i gotta swallow the whole chicken at one
go
yeah that's how i do it next slide
um
this is our essence everything is
designed with soul purpose this is our
proprietary seven-step
framework um sometimes you use
everything sometimes you use more so
it's kind of like a guiding principle
here um
purpose is almost given these days
but we always believe that if you ain't
got a soul nothing moves with it
so i will pick up two very quickly just
to run through today i think it's more
relevant the next slide
first is people
um a lot of times you talk about these
days like gen z gen y and whatever you
but
i would kind of use a marketing term of
tribes focus on the tribes who you know
people who share deep seated attribute
instead of going into like oh we got to
target these audience of that audience
so i mean the usual blah blah blah user
journey pain points are met needs but
one thing that a lot of people always
neglect are the internal folks here so
you always talk about external you know
the people who your audience your
consumers and so forth but to me a lot
of attention needs to be placed inside
like your team members your
uh whoever the internal stakeholders as
well
next
ownability so this is something very
unique because if you go to this
exhibition on this like this app or
whatever program
you will find that is very different so
how do you turn your brand's uniqueness
into meaningful meaningful experiences
across every touch points
and
think about
what are the things you can protect in
terms of ip and this is ip is going to
be the big thing just like for example
jackson's um zoo right try to copy the
idea he'll come after you so
something to think about as well next
um this is our belief it's a very simple
graph where
you know we always
adjust our outcomes according to our
intentions
and what's possible
and that way you kind of manage
expectations and you you sort of move
your outcomes
differently and becomes more interesting
sometimes beyond expectation
rather than
more friction because i'll show more
examples later on
uh next
and this is our goal we
we believe in this word called balance
and jedi calls it the balance of the
force right
so
they took that from buddhism
um we we try to balance everything we do
and to me perfection lies in the gray
area or
some call it off-white
um
so using our works i try to showcase
some of the things that we
we hope you can learn from some of the
things that i've put out here
some of our balancing acts of sort
i was quite
adventurous in putting a lot of works
inside but in the end i kind of regret
because it's short timing and too many
slides so i'll try my best here we go
okay this is the first one ideas and
feasibility design something more or
less you think you can deliver because
this one always almost killed us back
then when we designed this like oh we
want to do this clear crystal clear well
contain the new water you know things
like that and we call tokujin yoshoka's
factory in japan they turn us down they
say they only do it for him and no one
else
that was [ __ ] then we went around
singapore nobody can do it
we tried china and eventually yes
come hell or high water we got it made
in china and someone just experimented
after many explosions
we did it in resin clear as it so yeah
make sure you can get it done first
next one
recurring theme asian global a lot of
times it's like oh we have very
different audience how do you set an
idea to asians in the world
um so we always kind of because in
singaporeans ourselves we are quite
global in a sense so i always combine
something that is very uh you know
familiar to the east and the western
audience as well so in this case uh we
wanted to do something about science so
i increa included this periodic table
with the chinese medicinal hall
ideas so the different audience will see
different things and they'll get what
this thing means
next
um
we can always learn from only learn from
the past but
how we consistently and
always looking ahead of the future gives
us a very good sense of the now
so we we suffer from this
problem of like oh ahead of a curve you
know a lot of things we do uh like oh it
kind of be done or
the audience don't get it so this is
kind of like a
lesson we learned over the years like
how to always learn from the past
mistakes and you know kind of plot
the fun the flag in the future so that
you can understand what is that now the
past and future and now right next
uh hardware and hardware this is like
what i said earlier um at least one of
the clients
we have good relationship with bionation
where we use the heart to move people
internal team is very important unite
your team regardless of age and let them
shine as individuals so we develop this
openness for shared experiences and
and and let the guys be who they are
because originally they were they went
to another agency branding agency and
they asked them to keep all the old
folks at home you know keep them behind
don't show them to the world the young
people don't want to listen to the old
man but we think otherwise and today
mr chong is one of the oldest craftsmen
he has many apprentices who are like
um gen z
and they keep the craft
alive and he moves on so everybody comes
and feels at home
even the customers so they no longer buy
things but they support you yeah next
uh refreshing and familiar familiarity
this is a project we did for tong heng a
very old
history maker in singapore um
we they cannot introduce new pastries
they have what it is this is it
so
we ask them to shift things around every
day every now and then
so that you know you can spice things up
a bit and it worked so a lot of the
pastries that people don't buy or the
audience or the customers who has been
here forever oh new flavor i want this
and this and that but actually it's been
around from day one
almost 70 years
so
that works as well
be creative next yeah
um
heritage and modernity is the same
client
we managed to keep the old audience and
we win a lot of new audience how do we
do it i learned from lv you have
original elements you put it all across
all the touch points
and you vary the vessel like in these
days you see lv with the same monogram
with the same familiar icons or designs
they have it on denim they have it on
whatever
yeah so you tweak the two so that you
can achieve this familiarity with the
current and new audience
next one
physicality and spirituality this is
interesting because a lot of people love
the store we got a lot of good feedback
so learn to see and feel beyond the
surface what you can what what's
deeper than that so in this case we
design a store for the customers of
course the owners they have to be happy
uh the staff moving in and out and the
and most importantly we designed this
for the god
why i say that because if you look at
that black door at the back right the
door is very weird because the
contractor
and the japanese team that we work with
they kept asking why do you have the
door in such a weird height
you know because the trolley they push
in and out is shorter than this that's
it because there is a kitchen god
and his point of view needs to look
through
and ah okay so
after that uh when you know like after i
presented this whole thing the old the
very owners the fourth generation they
looked at it and third generation sorry
they say
i can see the gods good so everything
got approved so that was the main
turnkey
and the next one interestingly um seen
and unseen rebranding of death care
service
um how to extend the respect for the
ones you can see and the ones you can't
so we have journey mapping user journey
mapping it has to be extended not just
for the living but with we got to extend
it to the death to the to the disease we
have to think about imagine if i'm dead
what you know if i if i do come back
uh and if this ritual is for me how does
it feel like what would i want to see
and things like that so yeah
so sometimes you got to care for things
that you can't see as well
next project this is a single national
day parade
it's the toughest project one of the
toughest project because you're
commissioned by the military
you got to be approved by the civil
servants and every committee is like 30
to 50 people and you can imagine the
kind of commands you have
and yet it's designed for all
singaporeans so how do we do it um well
we play on something once again
familiarity
vary the proportions give you the
different context or show them in a new
light as simple as that that was a brief
to the team and we pull it off
uh next one is uh
buy now pay later growing very fast
globally but blame for getting used in
that so how do you how do you balance
this purpose and kpi at the same time so
for us always go back to your why
you have good intention and define your
clear why and stay on course no matter
how much
investment
valuation so on and so forth don't
don't deviate stay on course so recently
also we
also inform
i mean we work together inform the
marketing the social expect everything
down to even choosing the kpop um i'm
global ambassador
we also have our take on it to us to
tell them you shouldn't go with this
band even though they're top of the
world
nobody will remember you and their
values may not be lying with you things
like that so yeah
um this project is very interesting a
short video we did in 2019 to
commemorate the fall of the berlin wall
uh it was very interesting because it
was pre-coveted but we have
a lack of funds with lack of time we
lack of everything we cannot fly there
we cannot do whatever so we experimented
with like a you know zoom
and what have you we kind of directed
the guy in berlin and things like that
and
we died over this but we did it um
so we learned something before kobe that
even if you can't be there you can
actually remove the walls and you know
work together and go places together
having said that i would love to go
berlin
um this is my last slide a great
experience um can last can have a
lasting impression this one my favorite
album from jimi hendrix 1967. are you
experienced if you just wikipedia you
can find out all the funny stories about
this is it about acid trip is it about
chicken taking over humanity or at peace
with yourself zen so on and so forth
but doesn't matter the key point is
this wonderful experience that hendrix
and his band members did has critics and
fans
having this course
right until today
even after five decades so i hope
whatever work that you guys out there
are doing
it has an effect that everybody will
still be like wow you know this is it
i'm sure he can find its way into the
new method verse as well anyway that's
the last slide thank you very much keep
in touch
thanks larry thanks very much for uh
sharing your uh the diversity of your
project it's really fascinating to see
the different uh
the different media and and different
projects and different clients that you
worked on so uh we now have our last
speaker last but not least yes eric
everybody
please come on stage so i'm i'm really
happy to have you with us although not
physically to have been fantastic if you
could have come to singapore and to
share
your design thinking your experience
you are touching at so many different
design environments and very proactive
in innovating in all of this field so
i'm very excited to uh to listen to you
to your talk so uh once again let's
welcome eric and rick the first heroes
okay thank you uh yeah and all that
i think in the next 10 minutes i'm going
to share you some uh of our branding
works we've done for um from the various
times so when it comes to branding
project we we usually did a brand touch
all all of the brand uh touchpoints why
because to give a comprehensive
experience for customers about uh about
the branding so one of them is the the
experiential works
so these are some of the environmental
environmental design works that we did
so the first one is the co-working space
uh called co-work inc this branding
project done in 2014
so one of the core one of the first
co-working space in indonesia so we help
them develop all the uh all the logo
identity stationary marketing items the
local idea actually from the c and o we
kind of like
maybe met the cno interlock each other
to give an idea of connecting the
community
to communicate the vision of the brand
using the word connect collaborate and
converge so
if you see here they're on the third
floor of the fashion fashion
fashion retail outlet
so we did a little installation made of
laser-cut metal on the stairs with a
classic proverb
also we
we make we play around with the
footprint becoming a higher higher and
higher to show that you need to take the
stairs to reach the area instead of
using the
instead of using the stairs uh stairs
icon
so the next one is yeah uh we made some
icon for
for uh signage by combining two items to
put in
uh to put into a contacts like here
toilet paper and men and women's shirt
for toilet sign
also the owner has a uh
uh she got the
rottweiler
dock so we dedicated this uh wi-fi
signage to the
into her dogs
an open enclosed sign are still derived
from the cno when when it's open
we open it up and when it's closed the
scene pull it up so we kind of like make
this kind of a play around with the with
the branding branding idea into this
environment the next one is uh this
initiative project taken from my old
sketch in 2005.
so this is like a result of
contemplating process when i decided to
open my studio back then in 2005. so
uh i'm asking myself like whether i
should choose either gold or
gold or
glory which one is better or what if i
took the wrong path this is produced in
2018 and it's got exhibited in archicad
one of the biggest art fair in southeast
asia
we made a custom typography to create an
optical illusion and it's a gold gold
plated
if you take a careful look
when the word gold was reflected to the
to the mirror
it reveals the word glory so
uh we want to give a message that
perhaps these two words always have a
mutual value and could not be separated
at first at the end maybe it's something
you don't need to choose
maybe it's something that they both are
something that you need to earn at the
same time
got a good feedback from uh and response
from uh if you see this uh like the
social climbers to the their selfies and
posted in their social media
next one is uh kanpai this uh done in
2018 it's a izakaya
bar in north north jakarta
uh logo was created as the word khan and
pai were knocking each other me making a
dream
the idea of the brand uh taken from the
japanese red light district in shinjuku
we used this tanuki
racoon in japanese uh folklore as the
mascot kanuki was a mischievous nature
and is able to shape shift
and trick people
but when when they drunk we could he
couldn't hold these disguise
so uh if you see here uh still in the
red light district uh
theme uh that if you see the the menu in
the field menu we took from the core
magazine concept also as the the as well
as the drink menu
we think we took the concept from the
bootleg porn dvd with the parental uh
parent
advisory stand the bill holder also we
place around with the with the wordplay
using recycle can we put the word can
pay uh relating to the name of the brand
at the same time it literally made out
of use a team can
and the meaning of the word itself
telling us that we can pay the bill so
we have we had fun with this uh kind of
funds uh uh we're playing
to support the brand as well we created
this photo up spot
uh on the second floor
uh neon sign and some paint on the brick
wall resembling the the nightlife of
japan
we made this uh kind of a parody of a
glico running man that it's quite quite
iconic and became a landmark in in osaka
we changed his face with this tanoki
hanuki mascot
next one is a rooms inc it's a hotel
firm for a young travelers and business
person
the type of guests usually aim to use a
place to stay from sunset to until
sunrise so the logo is inspired
by the nature of business travelers of
staying overnight after office hours and
then took off
in the first morning light so we
stressed like this fits all into like uh
by sinking and rising hose
this concept of vice versa is uh uh if
you see here under the stairs of the
lobby uh we use this anamorphic
typography technique when guests arrived
and going up through the stairs they
will reap high
and when they're going down uh stairs
still tricks
by so we play around with this
anamorphic
techniques
in addition in addition to the branding
we also design wall installation uh with
the witty street smart messages uh found
in many corners of the hotel also in the
uh uh also in the room uh if you if you
see the wall we use a glow in the dark
paint on some of the graphic
so when the lights off it reveals a new
message so here if you see like a symbol
and then when
they turn the lights off they see the
moon jewelry is a contemporary uber uh
surfing chinese cuisine uh the name
journey derived from one of the great
classical novels of uh chinese uh
literature uh uh west
the jno of the logo type is composed
from the chinese ladder uh for your knee
the character of a monkey king if he's
here i was used in the takeaway back
wearing a chef hat
we did the chef as a as a hand of the
uh of the back
as a handle
inspired with the with the with the
original story we created this brand
concept which brings all four characters
came alive if you see here the monkey
king
and his friend have stranded the
displays while they're traveling to the
west
so for life-size sculptures holding
kitchen
utensils was created to complement the
ambiance uh with the humor and within us
he's here like the monk
as a manager
the monkey king as a chef and the the
pixie as the best boy who eats all the
life offers from uh from the customers
the bar also played around with the
chinese sliders like here
the
uh if you see the t is uh uh meaning cha
in in mandarin the toilet direction
stein was made as these four characters
stand on the uh
phenomenal cube holding up their p
so having fire having fun with the vip
room as well came up with this hollywood
walk of fame the footprint with their
signatures were casted on the stone to
leave the mark that they have been here
so the customer will feel this
four characters were really really uh
really really exists
next one is tender harmony uh it's
called a harmonious tent this project
brought by mld spot is a topic topical
company
in indonesia so they have this uh
special uh uh area uh bayer they have uh
this for for a japanese festival the
design was inspired by street food
fender culture usually set up of uh this
like blue and orange tarp hand
with some vernacular graphic fun easily
in the scene we try to capture immersive
experience
we collaborate with uh architect
lightning consultant and motion artist
to create this distinctive special
experience contemporary approach was
taken
by integrating materials found in
streets foot vendors such as like a
tarp gravel the polycarbonate concrete
plywood
we also developed a set of graphical
sets and also the the typography
all materials for this space were bare
we didn't put any finishing on the on
the row on the
raw materials the space design resembles
the first set of uh food stall very
easily when we eat inside the pan people
from outside can only see our feet if
you see here
only their feet
were visible
so uh we also installed uh
an interactive wall in the soundproof
room so where where when visitors can
create their own uh music when they
touch this cookie cookie utensils and
tablewares
so each of the tools has a different
sound tone and and beat
the next one is a splash coffee this uh
by done in 2019 tech based coffee chain
from rocket internet so you're european
tech company based in berlin
class coffee is expanding now it's like
several countries i think uh including
singapore bangkok philippines uh south
korean i think i think they have like
more
over like a 50 50 outlet
50 outlets
so the environment uh and
and ambience of the store following uh
the brand direction consists
consistently we have this kind of idea
of a yellow shop by making all the
interior in yellow so it would be easily
recognized
whether it's a standalone or uh or in a
mall we made them quite consistent with
the yellow colors
with all treatments like uh
there
uh i think this is the last one ali
malima is the newly refam food court in
uh one of the oldest small in jakarta
provide the local chinese indonesian
street food
the namely milima refers to uh uh
kakilima which refers to white food with
pedestrian pavement
so lima here we have reflected the the
number five into
into an a and we make this for for the
for their logo
to bring a familiar familiarity of the
street food experience the lima lima we
captured these iconic fissile elements
such as like an
animal silhouette
stall numbers or uh or even the receipt
you see here we twist them into like a
clean and modern look
the colors of lima
also are taken from the colorful
melamine plates used by the street
vendors
and we make this little gif
give
give animations
so this is for the environmental design
we applied the fairness color
typography
animal illustration install numbers soy
sauce label
we took the official memories from
from this uh vendors from in
chinatown chinatown area in jakarta
so if you see the uncle here the chef
with the multiple arms so we want to
show like this like this uncle is like a
jake of all traits of like or maybe like
a god gut of shifa so they can
he can do anything uh at once
so that's pretty much it uh thank you so
much for having me um
okay let's keep in touch
everyone
thank you thank you very much eric um
and it was late it made us traveling
because you know like in singapore
singapore has finally reopened a little
bit so we've been here for
quite some time so just by seeing all of
your
work like made us traveling so traveling
somewhere
so thanks again eric and thank you we
now start our q a so we will ask the all
of the speakers to
uh
come back on stage um and so
we received a fair bit of questions as
well
so if you can so larry steve
and of course eric to turn on your
camera
and so because we will
have
some questions a bit before we take the
questions of the of the audience
we will maybe start with a general
question so
um first of all
thanks for sharing all of what you what
you've been doing
very inspiring very exciting
and
for each of your practice it seems that
you are really going beyond one
discipline
we cannot you know like people like to
put some to put someone in a box that
you're a graphic designer you are an
entire designer but actually each of you
is doing a bit of everything
and in in that in your expertise in your
practice is it something that you
that you move towards to always go
beyond
what you've been doing
uh beyond your even your expertise let's
say if you're a graphic designer to go
beyond that so
maybe
can each of you share a bit with us
your journey and how you go beyond this
graphic design or interior design to
constantly play because that's what i'm
taking note of like playful each of you
is highly playful so maybe we can start
with with steve
how do you go
beyond basically your comfort zone to to
constantly design new exciting elements
it's quite easy answer it's like boredom
so
uh and disenchantment and
dissatisfaction so i started out as a
graphic designer and very quickly
realized that that just became the
foundation for doing a lot of other
things and um yeah it's natural to want
to evolve and try different mediums and
i'm pretty sure that other guys will
feel the same
and and so in this if i can just jump on
that before i ask
larry what was for you the the most
challenging
[Laughter]
very sorry like the food just arrived in
my house
no problem
well what was for you the most
challenging
design that you that that you took on
and that was really something that you
never did before and it was extremely
challenging but that you successfully
handle
well i wouldn't say successfully handled
but i think anything to do with
moving parts like humans at an event or
an exhibition you know there they tend
to be the most challenging kind of thing
um
and yeah with varying levels of success
but i feel like the low if you have low
risks in other words if you have no
client or like um
uh
you know it's a personal project and it
doesn't matter if if you're failing on
your own time i think uh yeah it's
probably irresponsible to try new stuff
with a client uh i think you need to
test bet it first
i think thanks uh for for answering the
the question and so larry on you're on
your side because same thing you are
pretty much cross-disciplinaries uh
among many different uh fields so
something for you like what what made
you going beyond what you are known for
and that
might be challenging and something that
you are still
like exploring and designing in this
i guess it's for me i've always felt
that the medium is
um
the massage right uh i mean my favorite
book marshall mcluhan it's where it kind
of
like
the wheels is supposed to make your feet
like a massage for your feet so we use
the car right
so if social media is the right way to
get it out then we advise trying to do
that but um
or if metaverse is the better way to do
it right now or in the early future yeah
let's do that
um so
i i guess it's about the voice
and and i've no regard for
i mean i'm not very concerned about the
microphone that you speak into
so everything else is almost like that
to me so if i need to have it as a video
um like the one
the the toughest one for me was the
berlin one of the project very top of
the berlin film thing because we just
say like why don't we just make a film
to commemorate and that's it you know
rather than having because the original
brief was supposed to do an exhibition
you don't budget to build an exhibition
and you know you invite the kids to come
they will be bought to death
yeah things like that so we created a
video for them so they can shoot it out
to their you know whoever
yeah but in the end
we
try to do it in-house
even a good friend wanted to help me uh
felix from anonymous he said oh you can
screen in my design film festival and
that particular freaking format is like
we have no idea how to even down save it
up save it and
yeah anyway
okay okay okay so uh thanks larry and so
for you eric like same thing because we
can see the diversity of your project
um including like
like special design and even involving
sound and then so
using different medium different
material
is it the core of your practice that you
always go beyond again your comfort zone
in exploring new territories yeah i
think uh i'm i kind of agree with steve
like uh i'm afraid to get bored
and maybe maybe
the right word is uh stuck so uh i'm
this if i got stuck like uh i'm i'm
already like 47 years now uh years old
now you don't you don't look at all it's
amazing
so so if i still um because because
we're we're starting off we were
starting off uh doing doing the logo
only for for the clients so uh if i
still do that
in this uh
recent time i think it's going to be
like uh i don't know so and and maybe uh
we as a human uh uh we have a
temptation to grow and evolve
so uh i think uh
simply just seek a new uh a new
challenge and
maybe to get a like a self approval
uh of ourselves and self reflection and
maybe yeah so so that's that's
the
uh the new challenges the new uh uh uh
something like uh we do we haven't heard
before i think that's quite quite
interesting
quite interesting for me
so i think to to to follow up i think
another question that has been uh i
think people are asking the same
question but in many different uh maybe
ways but you know we're talking about uh
designing for good and and you guys have
worked on many different uh sort of uh
projects with different clients and with
different subject matter so how do um
how do we measure or how do you uh
think that you either measure or should
measure the impact of the
of the design or an experience that you
have designed on on your audience on
your visitors on the people that are
interacting with uh whether it's an
installation or a printed
media or or something that's a
combination of different um
uh
different factors so maybe uh steve
again um will ask you that question how
do you measure the
the impact that your project has created
on on the people and the audience that
you're designing for
i think
really these are long term questions i
mean you know we used to make a magazine
called cult magazine
and i think it's only now some people
are starting to hear about it that's 10
years old um
and i think if you really want to hit an
audience it's like it's it's getting
away from social and going down to those
communities and
literally shoving a magazine into their
hands and looking at their facial
reaction um giving stickers out giving
like parties and and getting people
under you know actually meeting your
audience i feel like that's the way to
measure um
i think obviously if you're if you're
talking about a long-term engagement and
brand recall
uh
there's stuff like i don't know i don't
even care about it all i know is like in
order to convince someone what you're
doing is worthwhile and true
uh you've got to play the part and
really mean it
sure thanks steve yeah thanks thank you
and how about you larry what is the
how do you uh perhaps uh how do you
define uh uh
impactful project when it creates a real
difference uh maybe a great experience
to
uh to your client or to the people that
are experiencing it
i think from
my side internally it's easy to measure
it's uh basically conscience
so we only take on projects there we
our conscience will be clear so
that alone it's quite easy
um
and my clients like most of them would
have their own ways of management like
from marketing department to engagement
levels to google and so on and so forth
so
uh
those are not so concerned because like
you said i mean these are all statistics
but
for me i see the
the chain of people involved with this
um and the
not just the people the environment
i'm not really environmentalists per se
like oh you know you gotta don't print
it don't give name cards and whatever
but it it's kind of like how
because one of our sole purpose right
the s represents sustainability how do
you sustain your business
and how what impact do you
do to the environment
so there's two problems one is like um
for instance one of our client donghae
it's
it may not be a big project but to us
it's very meaningful we love that
you see because the impact is that when
it came to us the brand that existed
close to 90 years now
it might be no more
and the many family members working
together in this business
they kind of like oh you know he's
dwindling and they're not getting a new
crowd and all these things so
you have people who are kind of like
losing jobs if that's the case
and you have culture that is going to be
gone for so many decades here so there
are a lot of these things that we
measure you know the hardware part of
things
so the physic i mean these are
in a way another through time that we
have to set some
benchmark and milestones where we can
constantly go back and check on
sorry it's a it's a loaded questions i
hope i answered it
it's a very good question and i think
we move to another very loaded question
that i will address to eric
because we talk about good design for
good experiences or good design for
experiences
um and and i think larry you you
mentioned something about good design
and great design
and that is something that there is a
nuance here that is very critical and
and in in this when we talk about good
how do we
define good how do we set this
definition of good for a project because
good might mean something different from
a consumer a client a kpi or
like goodies so subjective is the same
as beauty so in and i will ask this
question to to erica how do you
set this how do you
like organize that in your work or how
do you embrace that in your work
do you define good and then how do you
work on that with a client for example
um actually um
i think uh yeah it's it's a very
subjective matters if you see if you
discuss about good or bad but uh
i think uh my our our uh
goal uh in every project is always like
a meet the objective of the
of the project itself not the
so uh we have this kind of a like a like
a questionnaire a simple questionnaire
we asked the client not what they love
but what
you want this project to be so that's i
think uh it's uh
if you get that kind of a
parameter so yeah you can like uh
squeeze a bit the the expectation
so that's that's that but uh i think
to answer the question about the
the impactful project
how do you
measure it
we live in a social media world now so i
think everything could be
measured
by just looking at the comments
and
yeah i think that's that's that's quite
practical for us now uh to to measure
the the impactful how how impactful the
the project is
and also i think uh
i have like a
my personal uh my my personal uh theory
like uh your your work is good when
somebody uh copied your works
so that's that's quite uh uh um
[Music]
yeah that's that's that's a bonus for us
i think
thanks uh thanks for addressing the the
two questions in one goal
and then we got about to watch tv
because um i i know very well your work
and and i do have your character
actually well your magazine
i don't have them um and and and even in
in this in defining good for example
um
what i perceived from what you what
you've done so far is very
thought-provoking
it's something that uh that really makes
us
like what is the meaning behind it and
and is it that for you for example
good design means
meaningful design of thought-provoking
design something that will make people
reacting and therefore an emotion
because good or bad is an emotion
so how do you how do you work on that
yeah i mean there's two types of things
one is the visual impact right you're
gonna make something that's arresting so
that you have
uh created a moment where you can
communicate so i mean you know we all
scroll through instagram and we see
millions of well okay we see thousands
of images a day perhaps
um
and
through that you really hone your
visual literacy skills and and you start
to identify what makes you what makes
people stop on certain images
is it color is it layout is it space is
it you know a combination of things now
all graphic designers think like this
uh
what i like to do is combine a sort of
art
uh you know a visual art aspect into it
where
there's a combination of of design
of of message and of a really kind of
provocative
not shocking but an image which provokes
thought exactly the right word
provocative
i think thanks for
for responding and maybe we can ask a
kind of contrary question to hillary so
so we talk about good design and
designing for good and and finding
meaning in projects uh but from from
your standpoint larry what would you
think is the worst thing that you could
do in a design or an experience
uh
so not necessarily that you you yourself
have done it but what do you think is
the maybe the wrong way to approach a
project or something to be aware of
especially for people that are
the young designers that are starting
their practices and starting to work
with clients so what what in your
opinion is the worst thing that you
could potentially possibly do i think
we're all guilty of it i think it's
jumping into uh any bandwagon
just because
because like what eric says we're in a
social world right
it's like wow
i i launched my netflix number one means
it's good but i tried it not my cup of
tea right
so
it doesn't make it great
if everybody loves it or everybody
watches it
so i think
it's uh it's like when something is
popular everybody jumps into it you know
it's like
i'm not sure if that's a
to me that's a bad thing
but we're all guilty of it anyway right
it's like no don't see don't see this is
bad we want to see what's going on you
know if the whole world loves it
yeah so to me um
i don't have any specific thing but
this is hot she's hot now he's great and
yeah you just go oh you kind of
condition yourself to say the same thing
so i always kind of try to take a step
back and say
is it really you know
or you're kind of like conditioned as
well with the social media and what have
you all there
sure sure definitely yeah
and you know it's like
yeah i think we're all kind of guilty of
that to a certain degree
i think a follow-up question to uh eric
would be um
uh what do you think um
what is your opinion on sort of the
impact of social media
guiding or affecting um design because
right now everything is kind of driven
by instagramable moments or or if you go
to an exhibition there needs to be that
that instagram moment so uh do you think
it's bad do you think it's good or do
you think
there is a way to find a balance
uh i think
if you use the the social media right i
think we it will be useful for us but i
think yeah the bedside of the social
media now i think it's uh everybody
tried to
copy each other maybe
so i don't know like uh
uh lately i saw a lot of uh mediocre
medical works uh over uh over the social
media so
i think uh you need to be
to be yourself maybe
you need to be you need to be original
or maybe not another you know i hate i
hate the word or you know but you need
to uh answer you need to have your your
own your own purpose and your your maybe
uh like like like lady said you see you
need to find your why
you did this uh you did this work so i
think uh yeah
just use it wisely maybe just uh yeah
and and and
avoid uh
avoid cliche maybe that's that's my
yeah thank you uh thank you eric for for
responding to this uh last question
because i think we're coming to an end
it is quite late already uh our audience
is still with us and we received a lot
of questions that
will be answered um like after the the
talk uh since you signed up to this talk
then you um
because we keep receiving questions so
they will be answered offline and they
will be sent to you since you signed up
to this talk um i just would like to
uh to thank once again our speakers
there is something that is that is quite
amazing in having you with us to
today is this um creativity this
creativity in pushing boundaries going
beyond the comfort and if it is
something that we can really take from
this talk today
it is beyond good design is what makes a
great design and i think each of you
here are demonstrating
um a really beautiful energy
to explore new territories to go beyond
your comfort zone uh to constantly
look for new things and and all of your
work are very exciting for that so it
was very inspiring inspiring for me i
hope that it inspired all of our
audience or wherever you are um i will
just quote i forgot who said that maybe
the larry
unite your team
and that's that's a very strong word
unite your team and especially in this
very hard time
let's remain united and unite your team
to push the boundaries and to deliver
beyond good design a great design
so
thanks again everyone thank you thanks
also design singapore for
uh for
organizing all of this talk and for
hosting us
please follow scgd if you want to be a
member
please sign up contact us we'll be more
than happy as you can see here
so for more events and there are all
like
so many things when you become a member
so contact us singapore
chapter us at scgdd.org
hola and myself will respond to you
and of course and of course to sign up
for our future talks which we will be we
will bring we will be bringing more
exciting speakers from uh from singapore
and from the region uh so we hope you
stay tuned and follow us and uh sign up
for more events to discover more great
talents around the region and uh make
them more accessible to the rest of the
world
so thank you guys thank you very much
thanks again see you very very quickly
for the next one thanks again and we
keep in touch thanks a lot thank you
goodbye
goodbye everyone